it is both a great pleasure and a great
privilege to introduce our guest speaker
today Mr rizvi Hassan who reaches us
from Dhaka Bangladesh
V Hassan has completed many projects for
the bangladeshis and for the rohingya
refugees in the world's largest refugee
camp in kutupalong
within five years of completing his
Bachelor of architecture at the
Bangladesh University of engineering and
Technology
Hassan received numerous Awards and
accolades in 2020 his Beyond Survival
safe space in technov refugee camp was
singled out by the guardian as one of
the world's top 10 new architectural
projects two years later in 2022 he
received the distinguished and much
coveted Aga Khan award for architecture
he has been named by the U.N a real-life
hero
and acknowledged by Ocha the United
Nations office for humanitarian Affairs
for his work with the rohingyas
Rufus V Hassan
has innovated on so many different
fronts broken so many stereotypes and
barriers that it is impossible to do
justice to his creativity in the space
of a few words
his architecture is a bold and Visionary
critique of the soulless shelters and
buildings being done all over the world
for impoverished population and for
refugees
and part of his success comes from his
profound engagement with the refugees
themselves before embarking on any
project rizvi Hassan holds workshops
with the rohingya refugees including the
children trying to find out their ideas
and their suggestions this of course
takes time because it requires earning
their trust beforehand but as a result
of this of these workshops he identified
Craftsmen crafts women artists
Carpenters Weavers teachers and is eager
to hear their ideas
and then they collaborate with him so
that the final project reflects what
they have suggested to him
The rohingyas Who fled genocide in
Myanmar are a status minority they have
absolutely nothing they possess nothing
but intangible heritage
and these projects
risby's projects with them reflect and
give body shape and form to this
heritage
Hassan has designed a series of centers
in different rohingya camps all with
different projects a cultural Memory
Center that addresses addresses issues
of memory and identity
a safe space for rohingya women and
girls
and a Hindu para Center for a small
Hindu minority the Muslim the the
rohingyas are mainly Muslim but there is
a tiny minority in the Hindu Paris
Center is extremely important because it
is shared with the Bangladeshi community
so with the host community
what stands out of this collaboration
with the refugees is a work that is
utterly sophisticated and known for for
the beauty of the exquisite beauty of
the detailing and the sense of color and
joy that emerges from these projects but
you have to see them for yourself and no
one is more knowledgeable more eloquent
in explicating his own work than rizvi
Hassan himself so in the name of
everybody who's attending this lecture
I wish to welcome rizvi Hassan to Yale
it is a real honor to have you speak to
us today thank you
thank you so much Esther uh for
introducing me with such kind words uh
I'm flattered to be here and I'd like to
thank the platform who organized this
and uh arranged his scope of discussion
between a larger community and
Bangladesh one
um
so uh basically uh what I'm gonna try to
do here today is uh share my experience
with the refugees in the past five years
so what we have done how we get to know
them
um and what were our observations and
learning I mean
working with them has been a massive
change of our own philosophy and vision
of life as well and uh I'll just try to
share this with you uh and uh I'd very
much like to welcome if anyone has any
questions or observations any kind of
kind of understanding uh please please
do share and we can have a discussion
um I'll just share the slides
so uh uh you know Bangladesh is a
deltaic landscape and uh this is uh one
of the largest Delta in the world uh and
uh and many Architects uh here has been
working on how really you need to work
on a changing landscape uh our whole
country is literally uh created on
sealed uh a lot of rivers a lot of
streams and that makes the landscape
changeable and we had the opportunity to
look look up on many great Architects
from Bangladesh who are already
practicing in the field and trying to
figure out these new method or new trend
or new technologies that can really go
with the lifestyle of a changing
landscape uh and and part of that as a
part of that we have been working in
different cities like Dhaka China boxes
or select and in different situations
um
and uh and the part of the journey was
to really uh determine who we are in
this landscape and what should be our
role as Architects uh in this country or
in this region even
um and that's how it started and we went
uh to the camp in 2018
I'll I'll tell you a bit about the cap
uh uh you know the influx happened in
2017. the big influx around a million
refugees uh rohingya refugees the fled
from Myanmar to Bangladesh uh overnight
and uh it happened before before 2017 as
well but that was like in a very small
scale
um like uh 20 000 people 30 000 people
they used to come from 1992 to this
country uh often in a regular basis
um but but this is the this is the first
time uh such a big influx happened uh in
2017 and it was a uh uh it was it was a
genocide to us what we could see
um uh whether it was official or not but
uh it was a massive thing and uh later
later they they uh started they started
building uh on the tech of heels the the
massive Camp was being built like
overnight you you see the this was
actually a reserved Forester package
what you see here and um and overnight
within weeks two weeks or three weeks
these all trees were gone and they were
just building shelters toilets to
support these massive community
and slowly it started growing like a
city you know
so what we observed is that uh from 2017
to 2018 it was kind of an emergency
phase where everyone really rushed and
give their everything to support with
the basic facilities I mean there was no
rules there was no wash facilities
people couldn't understand if they are
working on Mart or uh was it human waste
or it was very a messy situation I mean
one million people uh was a big deal and
uh
from 2018 to 2019 it was mostly like a
post emergency phase
um where it was more about how we can
organize the whole cap now on in terms
of planning Road networks facilities and
all sort of things and then the
development phase I mean we observed a
lot of things going on uh like I said
was mentioning mental health health
facility and your identity culture it
was all uh slowly being recognized in
this 2020 to 21 and 22.
foreign
this is a photo from China
we worked before the camp here and we
observed many people uh uh working
together like there is no architect uh
in this photo but how they really plan
the city together with the help of one
or two architects uh it was very
fascinating to us and we learned it from
uh another architect who is our mentor
and he does these collaboration with the
general people are also all sort of uh
community members and try to build the
environment together and we learned from
that and we tried to uh do the same uh
almost do the same in the very physical
context as we're very we're pretty much
fortunate to see that process in front
of our eye and later we were able to
apply that in the camp situation as well
so the people you see here these are all
our team members
in the last few years a lot of people we
found a lot of people who were working
there rushing to support the whole uh
situation and they were very uh
uh passionate people
who wanted to support anyhow with with
whatever they have in hand it it's it
didn't matter you see what a doctor or
an architect or whichever professional
professional you are everyone was there
to do anything
uh just day and night and uh we became
friends to them we designed a few
facilities for the situation and many
things went wrong I mean things went
right we started learning uh
it took us almost six months to really
understand uh the people there to really
understand the social sociopolitical
scenario there and what's going on what
where it should go to understand the
government rules what should be done and
what what should be the ethical side of
doing what we are doing
and
and slowly we try to experiment with
many
projects that we did uh in a very softer
approach like we didn't want uh anything
heavy or anything big or massive
in the in the early phase because we
could do a lot of mistakes there
so this is a project this is a project
for a rowing a women
um it's income 25. it's called a
safe space for uh rohonga Refugee women
and girls
um this is the first project where we
could really
collaborate with The Artisans with the
refugees and it was the first practice
to build some space together
uh
what you see here is a mix it is it's a
cam again it's a host Community as well
I mean you see a lot of Shades the blue
or the
white Shades these are mostly the
Bangladeshi community
uh the host hosting Nationals and you
will see a lot of shelters within this
uh context like this is a camp where
there is a mixed of host community and
and the refugee shelters like for
example on the right website this is a
refugee these are the refugee shelters
the the dense ones or the refugee
shelters that sort of thing and
what happened was we got to know from
our friends from that
gbv team gender-based violence uh reduce
deals with generals that a lot of
problems are advising
um because of this mix of these two
communities a lot of violence a lot of
threats a lot of conflicts especially on
uh women and girls that were being uh
that was coming to the scenario and we
were working with Prague at that time
and uh black decided to deal with the
situation and they said okay maybe we
can sit with them and try to consult
what we can do and maybe create a
platform where we can actually share
these thoughts and share these conflicts
and try to deal with in a legal way or a
professional way and uh
and uh this was uh this was a project uh
this was uh this was the space or
structure that you designed with them uh
it was suggested or uh the communication
was made with the women that uh what
they want to feel feel safe so they said
okay uh the camp is very brutal and uh
they don't they don't feel safe or
relaxed uh in any in any any room any
space uh you see all the boxy Shades
there they don't feel safe there because
people peek through and you can see
everything what's going on they can hear
you uh so what we suggested okay maybe
we can uh create an interior court open
up to them inside uh and which is very
colorful and vibrant and there are a lot
of layers surrounding to it and that
probably will offer you a better sense
of privacy
and this was the space you cannot really
see what's going on inside from outside
it's a very ragged thing but the inside
is very you have the colors I mean you
feel uh open up when you were in the
courtyard
and it was a success for us because a
lot of users were coming
um even I will I want to share one story
that I liked most about this structure
is that
we were observing many uh this sort of
facilities in other camps
and what we observed mostly is that uh
the male members of the community they
don't feel very secure to let their
female members go to such a facility
they think that it's a cultural threat
it's a religious threat and many issues
so they always used to say no to the
female members that don't go to a
facility uh who that is run by an NGO
without our permission and that sort of
thing
but
the fun thing is when we started
building this everyone started calling
this a stadium the male members
especially they were they were crafting
the stage and they said uh please uh
these were the Craftsmen and and they
said please hire us in this facility and
we said uh this is a woman facility why
do you want to be hired here uh they
thought for a while and they said okay
then I'll send my mother or my wife or
my daughter to to attend this facility
regularly so this was the first time we
thought okay maybe the space is actually
making some change uh I mean we didn't
hurt these from the male members for a
long time that they were trying to send
female members in a positive manner but
this was this story was a success for me
in this project and uh
and and now uh the host uh Community
come here the refugee Community comes
here and uh they often discuss about
their problems I mean it's a problem
it's a lot of problem in very regular
life but they get to have a sense of joy
in a space in a very brutal context
sometimes this space tends to a green
space and they let it grow and it's well
it's fun to watch that way
and later this is another project after
that one uh
this was another project in the
hindupara community center
um uh so so the Hindu Para
I'll talk a little bit about
refugee camp uh you see in the drawing
on the right side it's a very dense
settlement that is that is the small
camp for the Hindu Community uh people
who are Hindu by religion
um and in the left it's the host
community that is Muslim media
so you know rohingya refugees are mostly
Muslim uh 90 more than 90 percent they
are Muslim people uh but but uh this
small Hindu Community happened to
fly fled with them during the influx and
they were isolated from the main Camp so
uh
there was a conflict regarding uh
religion
um so they what what we found out is
that they were more insecure in terms of
like being friends with each other and
communication and everything when we
went there they were very
insecure that they thought we're gonna
again do some harm to them or break
their Temple or that sort of thing so we
decided not to work in the camp but just
adjacent to the camp so that it is a
softer softer approach that we do not
directly go inside the camp but we build
something nice and invite them and try
to build the trust slowly in the process
and then we thought okay maybe this
facility can be can also be used by the
First Community when the refugees are
gone so this was the structure where we
did also a lot of technical experiments
like all the panels are modular you can
really uh you can really dismantle this
one and shift it to some other place or
it's less less you wastage technology
that very modular design everything is
cut within the dimensions and easy to
install
uh
so this was the before scenario we we
found out uh we founded an abundant
shade that was a Chicken Poetry shade
but it was abandoned and we rented it
and we converted the same exact area to
a new space
I mean uh we didn't even try to plan it
or extend the rooms or whatever the
whatever we had whatever the room was we
just converted it to a new committee
Center
uh
and uh and you see the walls these are
all modular panels that are attached and
just made the steel frame these all can
be dismantled because the camp is a very
uh unpredictable situation uh we saw a
lot of structures being demolished
within night uh the the camping Church
government official they would they
would come and they would say okay we
have to move this from this side and we
have to
um uh we have to make space from
something else or something else so this
happened a lot and we thought why not
experiment with some technology or some
technique where we really can do this
this modular solution and this was very
uh
this was acceptable and everyone loved
the solution even the donor because the
donor they spent a lot of budget a lot
of money on this subjects but within one
year or two years these structures are
like gone and you cannot salvage
anything but in this solution you cannot
you can almost service everything from
it you can just use this any any Italian
and uh
and you see the color
um the essence the texture was very
important for us because we tried to
connect
with who there uh I mean with with their
skin color with their clothes uh what
they can relate to and it was not very
difficult because
we looked around the clues whatever was
in the surrounding and we tried to bring
the solutions and compose the solutions
and uh
it's and then later they had fun when it
was inaugurating they were painting the
space they were enjoying the colons and
everything
and in a similar Technique we built a
lot of structures for the hosting
Villages as well for the biology
Community not just rohinga refugees
um
because uh it was also about balancing
balancing the
conflict or peace between these two
communities because
the host Community they were arising
these issues that okay the refugees are
getting a lot of facilities uh because
of their influx where the host
communities are still poor and they do
not get anything and the government had
this rule that okay maybe 25 percent to
30 percent fund will be gone for the
will be spent for the uh hosting
Nationals and uh this was one project
that we did for them among several
and uh in the meantime we also supported
the government with our Solutions uh
this was a government building on the
left that was converted in a very short
time probably took three months to
design and construct
um now all the all the meetings all the
uh all the ideation or decisions are
made in this building uh this project
helped us build trust to the government
I mean they started understanding okay
an architect can offer something in a
very uh a very short time period and uh
they don't take like two years to design
and construct for three years now
uh but it's this and this is not very
perfect but this helped us a lot
and these are few projects we did later
uh in the same technique
uh we also did some experiments where we
used to live uh this is the left form
you see we converted it to the right one
uh the left home the owner he drives the
car uh he's from the community where we
used to live in uh we thought okay maybe
do we do a little bit experiment with
the uh here in the host community and we
did Enter space and turned into a studio
like this and he was very happy and he
is a friend of ours now
this is a
this is one project that we did
almost in the last phase of the camp
development uh
I mean after working in many other
centers or many other camps U.N iom I am
a U.N migration they they decided that
they wanted to
uh deal with the identity and cultural
issue of the
rohingya community and this was a
project under the mental health and
psychosocial support unit of iom
it started uh started with a few
cultural activities or creative
activities
and they tried to figure out who the
rohingya communities are with their
products with their techniques bamboo
we're being basketry which are stories
oral stories and stories from children
the elderly
and and they discovered that this is
this is a huge thing I mean their
stories
their culture their identity is
something that we are completely
overlooking we are just building shelter
shelter shelter shelter for them
but we are actually not
trying to understand that they are
actually a community that has their own
unique identity and a lot of stories a
lot of skills that they can share with
the world
and at that time Manuel Marcus Barrera
who was the chief of mission from iom he
was a very Visionary person and
uh he and the team they uh they
formulated this project over said okay
maybe we do a project that really
changed the idea of rohingya community
completely to the world
uh how we can do that
so we were involved at that time and we
were called uh and we started
um uh I started ideation okay what how
we really can involve and really can
understand and so what we did was we did
a lot of uh workshops and one-to-one
introductions and person-to-person
interactions that with the elderly with
the children with the female group
Community leaders and really try to
understand their stories as simple as
that
and we arranged some design workshops
it's in the camp you see the back the
back wall
is almost like turning down that is also
be breaking apart but this was our shape
these are this is our office space in
the camp and these were all the refugee
volunteers there and many were Carpenter
many were School teachers and University
teacher from the Myanmar uh
and they they started Gathering through
through this team and they shared all
sort of idea history uh all sort of
information and you see the boat they
made it here and uh this was this was
made by nurali Chacha you see the old
guy here he is a very dark type of
person uh a very haunted person and he
makes the most beautiful quotes you can
imagine in the community uh
so
we started having fun with these guys
having design session with this guys I
always remember that how we had classes
in the universities like uh I'm from
this University of engineering and
Technology I mean
we always try to
[Music]
debt in the camp I mean they don't have
to be the University students but we can
have the same sort of knowledge sharing
things we can have classes we can have
Studio tools we can do things together
and it was not very expensive because
they are carpeted they have the stools
and they have hostage materials and they
used to make this out of quite uh uh it
it didn't need much budget for that uh
and we found out a lot uh what they can
make and what they can draw uh what were
their imagination uh like in one one
Studio day we asked them to design a
panel uh a wall that no one has ever
seen I mean we didn't say anything but
just we said
design a weird one and uh this is a
drawing by Javed Bhai
um he is an artisan so he made these
panels uh from the that is the window
panel but that is that can be converted
to a table and a chair you know so the
wall is not just a wall it's also a
functional and we didn't ask for this
model from him but she made it either
way I don't know why but that excited
everyone
that said okay we are dealing with
something very exclusive here and
passionate people here
this this was his portfolio you can see
his name is written in the channel
so we try to find out stories things
uh even within the group of iom
in our office we try to
gather as much information
as we could because
when when we are dealing with a
community and where we're saying that
okay it's a rohingya cultural Memory
Center I am not the person to decide
who is rohingya
the information that I'll get if I can
compose that or assemble that or we can
make use of that for better men probably
that will give some sense of their
identity not all but maybe some sense so
we try to gather a lot of information
and uh
anyone's idea anyone's thought anyone's
comment
and we found out many techniques that
they use
again workshops you see the on the right
these are our Master Artisans teaching
to their students the nipapam technique
for the roofing
this this technical is almost lost I
mean in Bangladesh you cannot find it
anymore but we try to revive this
through them
and this is very effective this
technique is actually very effective I
mean uh we we use patch uh patch in many
rooms uh but that other catch the
problem of the catch is that has to be
replaced every year I mean every year
you have to do this investment to
replace the whole roofing system and but
this technique the NEPA
it loves it can last for 10 years uh I
mean if if you can type properly it can
last for 10 years so so we said okay
it's it's a big facility we cannot just
change the material every year we have
to
use this and and it also goes with their
culture
and another lotability is happened
you see on the left side this is a
drawing by Artisan an artisan uh we
asked him to
think of a meditative space or a
peaceful space while he will find peace
in the camp he he has drawn this plan
you know it has a lot of layer like the
world second uh semi-auto space and
there are rooms there is another space
and uh in the middle there is a court
here where you can see the light so so
subconsciously in our original design
it's translated somehow and
um you'll see the space now like this
um so so the idea of this space is it's
kind of a Living Museum people come here
they have trainings they talk to each
other they see the cultural objects uh
there is a display changeable display
all the time and it changes time to time
and there are some paramatics of it you
know so it's sort of a breathable space
for us within the cap I don't know if it
really uh
it's the definition of Museum but
uh but it's a breathable space for us
and the process it was class every day
every day it was a fun plus to attempt
and uh
and we also had uh concerts
so some rohinga uh singers they're
singing to entertain uh the Craftsman
the construction workers and that lifted
everyone's spirit
when we said look this is a rohingya
culture Memory Center and
you need to come come out come with all
the ideas I am not the one who is gonna
tell you what to do I can compose with
you I can help but you need to come up
with ideas and they came up with a most
absurd ideas you can see and most
beautiful ideas most with that technique
what they can do precisely with the
bamboo Bamboo with the cave with the
wood with the mud with art and they just
crafted the whole thing
this is a small uh wall of memories or
wall of Windows
um every every window is made by
individual an individual artisan and
that window says about their story or
memory you can you can open a lot of
panel and you will see a small flower
cow the rice field and and
that says a lot of stories in one world
to to be shared with a Young Generation
who is who is being born in the camp
never seen their past life in Myanmar
and they can just somehow relate to the
overall stories uh that the elderly
shares
is
that is questioned by
somebody made me a table uh this is a
very uh portable table you can fold this
one you can carry this on your shoulder
take two construction sites put your
laptop and work there like she was
observing that I work on Floors or on a
on a wooden panel whatever I get and
bring my laptop there and he said okay
I'll make you a table and this was such
a beautiful table I have never seen
something like this and I now carried
everywhere almost
he's at the final adapted spaces
that is
and uh the beautiful thing is whenever
we go to these places now I mean they
sometimes say
they just come to this space for no
reason and they come here they say they
talk to each other because
one shelter is very it's so it's so
compacted for like 20 20 family members
or 15 family members it's not very I I
mean it doesn't bring you much joy in a
complex combat space session uh or
sometimes it may stress you out so they
come with their family members or alone
to the space to have a sense of green
and sense of light and
the
uh in the middle that was dimitro he is
a psychologist
he is an Ukrainian uh
and we had a lot of conversations as
well as well how we can really
connect with mental health at this
creative process and
now he's uh he's in Ukraine he had to
leave the scenario before the
construction was over but he was
observing the whole process and he said
that this is the first time he saw
a creative process or our architecture
really has to do something with mental
health and it really connects I mean
when everyone was enjoying singing he
said okay this is something you can
really measure there is no doubt
and we send him photos uh
in WhatsApp I hope he's well his family
is well
but remotely the photos makes him smile
yeah
and
um yeah this place
this place now is actually a very
important one because almost all the
officials all the important officials
the government officials they come here
whenever they visit the camp they
definitely come to the rohingo culture
in the center to daily understand who
are rohingya and now they have a
complete different sense about this
whole community that okay this this
whole Community is not just a wild
Community or so someone who cannot do
anything no take and do a lot of thing
and they cannot be neglected the world
has to
take this community seriously no matter
foreign
migration
maybe that was an international
migration or uh what we were dealing
about what the refugees but internal
migration is a big issue in Bangladesh
as well
um people people are living their homes
in villages they don't have much clue
what to do in villages anymore and they
try to get to the city the city is a
mess messy situation there are slums
uh I mean in in a lot of case this is
worse than the refugee context there's
no competition definitely but uh in a
lot of cases they people don't care
about
the villagers who go to the slums stay
unhealthy
um no life I mean so
now what we're trying to do is we're
trying to enter into these Villages and
um
trying to create some sort of example
that
that will tie the people with where they
are that will create good examples in in
the community and build on on the place
you don't need to really shift for life
to the to the city yes you can go to the
city you can go visit you can go for
different facilities but you don't need
to leave what you have for such a
beautiful landscape you have and uh
how we can really create good examples
in The Villages that is our Prime goal
now and we are working on that we're
trying to
plan with them share with people this is
a product from
one same Workshop like in the morning
the key to us doing this and uh in the
hall this guy was like they were doing
the same thing and it was
we were surprised to see the
similarities of these people uh the kids
and the people so the 30 years everyone
enjoys this the drawing the building
together and
and uh in last year there was a flood in
uh stilet area
we went there for a very short time
tried to understand
uh what is happening what can be done
um and try to learn a lot from them as
well
and we made a small uh small raft for
them that can be for the madrasa for the
mother's children because uh during the
flood that the lands get very isolated
people don't get connected often cannot
get connected or they cannot carry their
Furniture their household items to a
safe place so we thought okay we we went
there for a week and uh we experimented
on a on a raft
how this can be maybe a tiny classroom
or and it can be used as a transport
during an emergency
um it was just uh it was
not really a project but it was a
project where we can really
get into the context get to know with
the people
um and we made some friends there we
found some Artisans some female Artisans
they make beautiful weaving mats
I have never seen this in Bangladesh in
anywhere
we found those beautiful pieces and this
last last week maybe we brought those
meds to dhakad Summit there was an
exhibition and they were sold to people
and this fund went to The Artisans The
Familiar defense from these rural areas
to connect like
rural spaces where they have they
probably have not seen City much
but they are now being connected they
are exhibiting their product to a
exhibition in Dhaka through us
uh we're just trying to be helpful
anyhow
um even through a toilet like we wanted
to design a toilet because that was
their primary need one of the primarily
it's a nice uh healthy toilet and we
offered them that we had some fun and we
said okay sure sure don't just waste
this on rice or I mean because they had
the food many people were coming with
food rice lentils and everything but
they didn't want it they didn't ask for
it
um so we thought okay maybe on an
emergency we can do many things
to sometimes it is we provided them with
materials what they can repair things
with some with this sort of toilet where
they can later extend and make it a
washroom as well so it was always
organic it was never one decision that
we are going for this and to this no we
always try to go to the context and try
to understand okay this this should be
the appropriate and we try to do that
maybe next time we don't build at all
so yeah that's that's uh
for a impermanent life I think
presence is very important because it's
always changing it's always new
decisions it's always new understanding
and your presence can make a lot of
change that that's our observation
whenever you are present there you are
still there and you try to understand
who you are working with and what is the
purpose if if the budget if the charity
yeah if whatever resource we have we
have in hand
if we try to figure out uh that we don't
need to do everything we just need to do
the appropriate thing sometimes
try to figure out what are the
appropriate things and that's when
magic happens and uh that's how we are
calling it a presence for a quite a
spectrum thank you that's that's all
from me
uh stop touch slide I just have a a
couple of uh questions uh which is uh
which are like
in the pictures that you've shown there
are lots of greenery and trees around
and in some other pictures that I have
seen
uh from the refugee camps rocking a
refugee camps in Bangladesh they are
very dry is that the misconception that
of the picture that I have seen before
or did just happen to be that where you
build this Center there were all these
trees that have been there for for a
while because I think that gives a lot
of
I mean it's like a transition in between
the the place it gives a sense of of
peace and Tranquility rather than seeing
all these dry space around
the most photos you see that is in ukia
the uh that is the most concentrated
Zone uh but we we also have a lot of
scattered Zone in the periphery
um which which really matches with the
host post Villages hosting villages
um and the projects we have I have shown
you in the first the first two projects
those were in those areas where the
refugee Community is merging with the
host communities and those actually
support both the refugees and the host
Nationals so those are very uh those are
still green uh but uh for for example
the cultural Memory Center uh that is uh
exactly in the middle of the whole cap
and you see all the shelters surrounding
um but the good thing is when you go now
you will see a lot of dream people have
worked on that on projects how to make a
cleaner cooler and how to revive
whatever we had
um but the first two or three articles
very better very well it was it felt
like a desert
um but now uh now the scenario is a lot
better the green is there uh it's cool
the camp is way more livable
USB
yes thank you so much for that very
moving and very beautiful talk I mean
the work is so creative and I was struck
again how you have offered the rohingyas
with whom you have worked a support for
heritage
and so on both Heritage but then this
and memory
and so the architecture becomes a
conduit for this but I realize also it
becomes therapeutic so you do address
mental health that is one is one of the
very strong things that you really it
comes across that it becomes therapeutic
and so I wish you would talk a little
bit more about these and the stories
that you shared uh which are so powerful
and they are unique you are I don't the
only you're one of the few architects
who who've worked with genocide so that
already puts you in a unique position
yes uh I mean uh from our perspective uh
what we try to do is
um
at the beginning we we thought maybe
it's just trauma that we are dealing
with it's just bad memories and the
genocide
the general site was such a difficult
time for them that we overlooked what
they had in past a good memories
and uh and we were people who were not
focusing on how you uh get rid of that
trauma that you had but they were not
talking about what good memories you had
what songs you used to sing what what
you used to have so sometimes I don't
know probably memory and understanding
probably we we understand it them
sometimes that
um probably it's a compartmentalized
thing that uh we think their refugees
that's how they need to be treated in a
way but they are also regular human
being as well right so uh what they have
they like to have joy they like to dance
they like to be motivated
they don't always like like to talk
about what they're going to no they
don't uh they all they often get very
disturbed I mean whenever a journalist
is coming and asking all these difficult
questions that stress them out but when
you are going
sitting with them at least in a tistole
and talking about you know who is your
girlfriend who is your boyfriend
that's that's when they start enjoying
okay we have a life in Camp we don't we
have we have not lost everything
we have the hope to grow from here so
that was our Technique we never we
always try to avoid uh uh from our side
to talk about the genocide or the tough
situation uh
try to make the event joyful and but
there has been a lot of time where
people used to come to us and seek for
help like little girls
um and uh guys who were in trouble and
in many issues and we used to say okay
go to this person he can help you the
government can help you is to refer them
uh but uh
so we were very aware that okay they
might come to us with these problems
that is okay but uh no we don't have to
talk about that always so that's how we
try to enjoy that's it
so we have a question
um from Anisha Saha
um she's from the Department of South
and Southeast Asia studies at the
University of Calcutta and she says that
um the work that you recently are doing
is absolutely something the words need
to admire and take inspiration from and
her question is regarding the data in
relation to gender-based violence in the
camp
um
that often led to early pregnancy among
teenage girls is there such a case in
Bangladesh and if yes how is the
organizations you work with are dealing
with that
and the second question that she has is
that when you are in the process of
building this lovely shelter was there
any encroachment issue race upon the
organization by the government or any
other Dashi original National
um so the first question is yes
definitely I mean it happens a lot and
uh in our team uh we always try to have
uh energetic female members uh like
kajafati who is also an architect she
used to work with us in many projects
and volunteers like female volunteers so
these were because uh a lot of these
issues used to arise and they used to
come with these problems little children
adolescent cards and they they never
used to share this with us definitely
especially not the guys but they share
it with another female person and that
happened a lot of time and there are
special uh Team gender Bill Palace team
who has the counseling service who has
the Case Management Services
and they deal with these issues any it
is any complex issues that arise
um they try to offer any health related
surveys they try to offer any legal
related service
so Prague action8 and many other
inventions they have these services so
the the center you saw in the beginning
that has a 4K inside one of the room is
a counseling room one of the room it's a
case management room so there is uh
always someone there who is there to
support these females maybe because they
often don't share this in front of
everyone so we had to make some private
spaces so that they can come and feel
safe and share this in a private manner
uh and another thing encroachment uh has
not been an issue because the government
in the beginning
they
they set in the map in the plan that
this land will be for the camp and when
we we used to build in the host
Community or in a village we used to
have this dealing with the landowner
that okay we are renting this for five
years or six years and they give us the
land and we build a structure and we
have this understanding okay when we
leave you can use the structure or the
community can use the structure that
something so encroachment was
uh you mentioned that the roofing the
the thatching technique that is used uh
goes with the culture and I was just
wondering if that is something that has
been uh in place you know forever or is
there more of a story that you could
tell us about how that technique relates
or is integrated with the culture
the roofing technique
yes so uh the NEPA technique that what
we found out is that we talked to this
Craftsman and they said almost 90
percent houses second Myanmar they used
to build this with with this material so
about Nepal Leaf is that this grows on
the salty canals uh only only in the
salt water sites in the kennels
um and you cannot find it in in regular
water area or something so in Myanmar
they grow a lot of these leaves and they
used to have deal with this Leaf a lot
and space specifically the technique
that you have seen in the photo uh they
associ
leaves with a stick of bamboo and use it
like a tight you know one on another and
uh one one day what happened is that uh
uh uh we made a sample of this and we
are we're taking this in Hand by hand uh
uh with us uh in the campaign many
people started Gathering and they said
why did you get this this is from our
home and random people from the camp uh
so that's how it was connecting we're
saying okay this is really working I
always thought okay why not maybe add in
some workshops uh we were sure we are in
this Workshop in another camp in Tech
now to distribute the knowledge from the
elderly Craftsman to the young who who
doesn't have any clue about the uh
technique
um even for our country this was used
before but now they don't use it anymore
so it was learning for us as well we
didn't really know about the technique
we learned from them uh now in the
dhakad summit we made a wall with the
nippa Palm leaves and many people
started asking okay is it a coconut Leaf
I said no this is a name that you should
know and you should use so so that's how
it's disconnected
hi I have a question if that's okay uh
first thanks so much for sharing your
work with us it's really incredible and
I wanted to ask if you have any advice
for students
who like architecture students who are
interested in working with refugees in a
similar lens to you since um like I'm
I'm from I'm Esther student at Yale and
like resources online tend to be either
very limited or just limited to formal
organizations like the UN and there's
also this added concern of it having a
sort of like
neo-colonialist approach for students
who are not like local to the region
um
I mean yes uh
uh if someone is not local or they don't
have much difficulty to have these
connections build connections and
everything it's okay I mean you can
build a team or you can get connected
with the team with the locals with the
refugees make friends with them and try
to connect
in a voluntary manner or with an
organization whatever uh whatever the
scope is but it is possible because uh
many uh many uh
artists or other professionals from
other countries they started working
with us they are they are working here
still and what they do is they team up
they have a local person they have some
volunteers from the refugees so there is
a system uh where you can blend in it's
uh when you come to the context You are
not alone you are not really dealing
things alone so but the key is What is
your intention if you have the intention
to help uh if you really want to come
with everything you have and try to be
useful people will understand that you
are useful and they will take your help
was
yes
and if you if you can come online I'll
be very much happy he was the curator of
uh the project
he is an artist he's a filmmaker he has
been uh he has been a huge thing for
this project also uh you have seen uh
one photo of him like working on the you
know uh Workshop uh one of the workshops
so uh a lot of ideations he he has been
a a our teammate our project manager for
a long time and we did this together so
uh what was that question David if you
can ask directly at the can you hear me
yes David how are you long time no see
you congratulations on the awards and uh
and and all the world I'm really happy
and glad to see the final result thank
you so much
and yeah my question as you know uh it
was quite a complicated project they are
CMC yes
before you arrive and after I left
let's put it that way uh there was
actually a question there from somebody
who was asking whether you had face
adversity by the authorities and Camp
managers and the government
uh I think that was quite a
common as you could explain or
you know it's not as straightforward as
building anywhere else in the world
because it's acquired temporary space
and we don't know for a whole long
they're going to be there and also
there's all the situation and that has a
lot of
complexities uh yeah but my question was
more about the collection so as you know
we sort of conducted a massive cultural
mapping with the community and
which landed in a sort of production of
a lot of objects over a thousand objects
and tapestries and so on and although we
have different ideas and there was much
consultation with the community
this this defined different areas as you
explain are pottery and Architectural
models and boat making and and so on you
know the tangible and intangible all the
music that we recorded in the YouTube
channel and so on so all this was like
the material that was supposed to
influence the the space and the walk
through experience and and and and and
and in the best of
the capacity that we we were we were
able to put this together and inform and
validate by the community and and inform
uh your skills you know I'm very glad I
found you because we had a previous
architect before which I wasn't a very
good person so you did an amazing good
job so I you know your your engagement
with the community is a primer I have to
say so
congratulations on that one and um but
yes you know to me it's like the
physical you know the the
shaping of of the yeah I mean yeah
um uh so about the cultural Memory
Center I mean it already took place
with you guys uh with you there's a
manual there was uh dimitro there's
other other teammates Raju Bhai and it
was taking already taking some organic
form before and then then you guys uh
had us in the team and then it shifted
to some another paradigm so the the the
process of this uh whole project was
fascinating to me because we had to
really act on
what was the demand of the time
it was the complexity of the government
from the government it was the
complexity within the organization what
we can do what we cannot do and uh from
the specially from the government
because this sort of project is not easy
to get the permissions of the government
you know and we had to seek the uh we
had to wait for the permission for a
long time
and I had to change the drawings the
design simplify it as much as possible
for a like five or six times and present
it to them
um so it was always the point we're
saying is presence for a wider Spectrum
if we had uh given up at that time okay
the government is not agreeing with us
the first two times or three times then
this project wouldn't happen right so
what we try to do
with whatever we have we have the
opportunity to do without breaking the
hormone uh without breaking the social
political scenario with it without
harming anyone or attacking anyone
what is the best possible thing we can
do that's how we simplified a lot of
things of course you uh I remember you
had the major guidelines were built by
you designed by you that what should be
the inside things and uh what should the
curation the narration
um but but then we faced when you left
we faced these uh issues from the
government that you cannot do this
project in the camp and uh camping
Church uh he was not convinced no this
is this is subcultural project that is
not applicable in the camp so what we
try to do we try to shift it a lot to
learning things uh like learning Space
Trading space and we tried to we had to
convince them that this is a mental
health facility this is something that
is related to mental health their
culture is there but it's not a luxury
thing or it's not something uh that you
can have in Taka or other cities or
other communities what can be the
translated version for the refugees what
can be the simplified way to not uh
really be a threat to also the hosting
Nationals we had to take that in mind
and I we simplified a lot the fuss ups
were like Organics you are know if you
remember but there was a large port on
the outside of that we had to erase all
of this right and even during the
construction it was really
I'll tell you during the construction
period we got the support from The
Artisans but
um the time was shown we already lost a
lot of time for the covet period
and and during this time I don't know
this was the best thing we could come up
with and I said it's a it's a it's the
memory that we will carry during the
making of the tiles the partitions and
even the curators the present tutors
they are working on the new products the
new things and I'm sure they are just
working on growing the whole thing more
and more uh I'm not in touch with the IM
team anymore uh but I have the
communication with Artisans and I often
see photos what's going on and they are
gradually growing they are making small
village jails or whatever we had in in
mind I think I think it will not stop uh
it's it's not a it's not a fixed thing
that we're looking at it like if they
stay here in five years probably you
will see something
more crazy growing there
no for sure I mean you know the
guidelines were set and the map is there
to be explored and expanded but to me
the the soul of the building is was all
these objects you know I remember before
there was a building you know because to
me was I was her as a curator of a
center that didn't exist of a collection
that didn't exist so I have to create uh
you know the team that will create with
the community the whole a collection
that will tell a narrative and and you
know and you have to make a building to
shape that narrative you know yes so it
was quite an impossible project because
the UN don't do cultural centers no no
anywhere in the world at least in a
refugee camp
so yeah people have I mean uh well we
have what we went through to make
um and Manuel you know Manuel you know
also he have to deal with many things we
all did yeah yeah but I'm glad you know
it's finally there and in some sort of
shape and content is evolving into
something that the the community tank
can hold on onto in in the adversity of
what they are facing which is unclear
how long you know they have to be there
you know for sure it is uh frame into
the mhpss sort of framework because
that's how it is justifying the U.N
system but yes it is very cultural
exactly but but what's the most
beautiful thing is uh what uh you uh
shared with Artisans the trainings the
the house model making I mean even if
this production gone these people are
the Living Legends of the community now
I mean you cannot deny that even if the
whole facility is not there this team
this massive team is there to share to
do all the right things for their
community and that's a huge success of
you of the team of us together
yeah they're growing into they're
creating their own life and culture they
didn't know exactly you see we are the
Catalyst yeah that provide them with the
opportunity to be their own creators and
to and to be the culture man and and
sort of delete that cultural revolution
anyway I will not uh start maybe I
should let you keep going uh thank you
very much
hi I actually have a question as well
um I already dropped my question Chad
but I thought it'd be nice if I asked to
hear I'm just wondering if you can speak
a little bit more about the role of um
he's building humanitarian organizations
non-profits and and international
agencies in making the project that you
do happen
um because you mentioned the iom you
mentioned black and a few other
organizations I'm just wondering
um whether their role in making your
projects happen are mostly on the you
know funding um the program design side
in terms of the overall Community
Development programs
um or they're also providing you know
access to communities and also helping
you lead with the government so that to
make sure that um you kind of meet their
vision and their requirements
um yeah just speak a little bit thank
you
yeah
I mean um
we we had this confusion that uh whether
we can explore through the strict
systems of uh un or other organizations
and do this uh and not non-conventional
unconventional things but we had to take
the uh coverage to do that I mean the
funding was there the projects are there
and they uh and you know the project has
some sort of guidelines but when you are
there as a catalyst and you say this is
the right thing to do under this project
there is always chance to improvise
there is always a chance to make it
shift it a bit uh in a right direction
uh and come up with a nice uh uh I mean
very appropriate thing I would say
um we often think okay these are the
projects I have to just do this that is
the biggest
criticism of ngos probably that they
always operate from outside they bring
the funding they have to just do this
this fill up the checklist and uh
sometimes it's a mess instead
um but in many cases it's not a mess
it's actually very helpful and very
beautiful and that's all because of the
person who is there who is operating I
mean Indra organizations I have met so
many brave persons so many dictionary
person who actually could think in a
creative way in a in a Visionary way and
they could improvise whatever they need
they could even come up with new
projects like like the rcmc the broken
culture Memory Center the team worked to
build this project right they they
created this project under under mental
health
um so so uh there is always chance for
the people who are in charge to really
have these Visionary decisions and if
you can really encourage them come come
up with a nice idea and slowly you don't
have to always post them just slowly
have discussions and there are a lot of
people a lot of positive people to do to
really make change there are a lot of
people people who don't want to do much
they want to just do their desk job but
a lot of people are actually making
change and they are actually do these
benefits to the people
so I was uh just asked to thank you for
this extraordinary
really deeply moving presentation we
were honored to hear you and we look
forward to having this posted on our
website and look forward to continuing
to follow your career and congratulate
and salute you for everything you have
done for the rohingyas and the the path
you have shown to the profession that is
no mean feat is an extraordinary
achievement so thank you thank you so
much thank you very very much and thanks
to all of you for being present
um at this event uh we will certainly be
following rizvi Hassan as he goes along
in his career thank you
thank you so much for having us and I
really enjoyed the time I hope to see
you again